il ya de grosses boulettes chez
boulanger howell doit présenter d'ici
quelques temps j'ai pas la date exacte
un autre smartphone c'est le p smart
ils ont déjà tous publiés avant
[Musique]
je pensais tout le truc faut savoir que
les fabricants enfin du moins les
distributeurs envoie aux revendeurs donc
boulanger fnac darty cdiscount les
compagnies dans le monde entier
toutes les informations sur un produit
avant même qu'il soit présenté comme ça
le jour j ils peuvent publier sur leurs
sites dès lors que le produit en ligne
pour les précommandes la fiche technique
tout en ligne tout est parti donc ça
s'est fait avant et notamment il le
renvoie la petit descriptif comme ça ce
qui leur permet de créer leur fiche
produit
ça c'est le fonctionnement de base alors
ce que font les grandes plateformes et
amazon cdiscount et compagnie boulanger
entre autres ils vont préparer la fiche
produit ils vont la remplir avec toutes
les infos que vous retrouvez ici à
l'intérieur donc toutes les specs qui
sont un marqué ici ils rentrent leur qui
se produit ils ont les photos du produit
et ne publie pas il l'a publié
uniquement à la date et à leurs données
va le fabricant il dans le milieu de la
presse appelle un embargo j'imagine que
là c'est aussi à peu près la même chose
vous avez une information vous n'avez
pas le droit de la divulguer avant que
le fabricant vous donne le feu vert
voilà donc à ses principes donc je pense
que chez le boulanger quelqu'un a saisi
et la fiche produit au niveau numérique
et au lieu de mettre une date de
publication à l'heure est aux jours
indiqués
ils ont dupliqué sur publiés du coup la
fiche technique s'y retrouver en ligne
c'est parce que ça a dû gueuler chez eux
c'est un peu compliqué je sais pas
combien de temps la fiche technique est
restée en ligne google a indexé et
lorsque vous êtes sur site de boulanger
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt accessible je
vais sur google et je vais taper huawei
fait smart 2019
boulanger web et smart 2019 boulanger
j'ai ici la fiche produit web et smart
2019 noir je clique et là j'arrive
effectivement sur une page boulanger où
il n'y a absolument rien et j'ai un
message classe en train de traiter la
demande est là j'ai un message attention
nous sommes désolés ce produit n'existe
plus nous vous invitons à poursuivre
votre visite
miller smartphone alors ça ça veut dire
qu'ils ont supprimé la fiche produit
néanmoins je reviens en arrière le jeu
hickson petite flèche je vais en cash
dans ce que google a enregistré et la
magie qu'est ce que je vois la fiche
technique du huawei petsmart 2019
ça c'est le modèle noir il ya une autre
couleur 249 euros
et là j'ai toutes les caractéristiques
techniques je peux télécharger la fiche
produit
j'ai téléchargé qui est juste là et je
vois exactement tout j'ai tout tout tout
tout tout sur le produit j'ai toutes les
caractéristiques techniques c'est
hallucinant bien évidemment l'info a été
reprise un peu tous les côtés sur
différents sites spécialisés donc du
coup on va pas se priver de regarder
quel est ce web et smart 2019
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans le vent
peut-être qu'on peut faire donc on va
regarder un petit peu ensemble du côté
de la fiche technique
voilà la fiche technique du produit tu
es smarves un écran yalda bon sens va
regarder des chars votre smartphone vous
voyez ne serait-ce que le design on a
une petite encoche en goutte d'eau comme
on retrouve sur le mail 20 de huawei
module photo directement à la verticale
double module photo flash led un petit
menton en bas il ya deux couleurs vous
avez une colère noire et la deuxième
couleur c'est aurora bleus ça un dégradé
de bleu bon sympa vous avez l'audace ici
à 0,83 bon voilà ça c'est pour cette
partie là ensuite on voit qu'on a un
écran alors écran foullezou de 6,21
pouces cool fhd plus assez cool 2340 par
1080 ltps et du lcd ce qu'on voit là
dessus c'est vraiment les usages en
termes de multimédia qui vont continuer
avec des écrans avec des belles
résolutions des grands écrans ça c'est
cool performance un kir in 710 il a 3
giga de ram 64 giga de stockage
extensible en microsd jusqu'à 512 ça
c'est cool android 9 paillot km 8,9
points 0 ça ça marche au niveau des
photos on à 1,13 plus deux avec
autofocus le 2 servira pour le mode
portrait le trait ça sera le capteur
principal est à l'avant vous avez un 8
mégapixels un capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui se situe ici là juste à
l'arrière de l'appareil
vous avez une batterie 3400 milliards
perdus nous donne jusqu'à 800 heures en
veille et 25 heures en autonomie
batterie 3480 erreurs on doit pouvoir
tenir à la journée sans le verra
lorsqu'on le testera on a donc une nano
cible et on a ensuite soit une autre
manne au sim soit une carte micro sd
donc ça c'est au choix bons réseaux 4g
on s'en doute wifi bluetooth 4.2 nfc oui
on a du micro usb si pas d'usb type c
pas de rechargement rapide là dessus un
smartphone qui fait 160 grammes dont les
dimensions on les a là contenu du
coffret chargeur câble usb guide de
démarrage outils déjections la carte sim
cartes de garantie un grand classique il
est dispo dans découle dans deux
couleurs en noir et en aurora bleus ça
c'est leur aura bleus voilà un peu pour
l'ensemble de cette fiche technique du p
smart 2019 ce qu'on voit également sur
les photos qui sont dispo sur le site
c'est qu'il a une prise jack
en bas à côté du port micro usb il a un
haut parleur mono
du coup un bond passant espérant
smartphone milieu de gamme donc on va
pas dans un truc hyper hyper fou et le
tarif attendait il est dispo sur le
style de vos rêves ou l'a vu tout à
l'heure 249 euros
voilà pour les infos sur ce smartphone
alors bon l'erreur est humaine
c'est arrivé chez boulangiste c'est déjà
arrivé de d'autres vendeurs hors france
nous ça nous permet d'avoir est la fiche
technique connaître ce produit avant
même sa présentation ce qui coule c'est
de voir que ce paceman de 2019 continue
vraiment dans la lignée de ce qu'on a pu
voir d'ailleurs des smartphones avec des
gouttes d'eau avec des tout-petits
menton des produits vraiment optimisé
pour le multimédia et c'est vraiment là
dessus qu'on va continuer d'aller en
2019 du multimédia avec des grands
écrans donc d en cochant goutte d'eau
des découpes dans l'écran par des choses
comme ça pas vraiment des très grands
écrans de l'immersion pour du multimédia
est le deuxième point ça va être la
faute aux relents d'un 13 mégapixels on
connait pas l'ouverture on n'a pas
toutes ces infos là on le verra
lorsqu'on le testera on est sur un
smartphone aussi milieu de gamme
on va pas non plus avoir un truc
complètement dingue mais en tout cas ça
plutôt cool voilà donc je sais pas vous
dites moi ce que vous en pensez comment
vous trouvez se paie smart 2019 ont
marqué tous en commentaire et puis on
sera un plaisir de tester ultérieurement
et puis une fois de plus
c'est une erreur humaine je suppose en
tout cas chez boulanger c'est
actuellement plus en ligne
merci google et à la fin c'est un peu
embêtant de boulanger qu'on puisse avoir
accès à la version du cash
c'est comme ça c'est les règles du web
terc chez boulanger va pas être un
problème par rapport à cette personne
qui a commis cette erreur ça peut
arriver
en tout cas merci elle parce que ça nous
permet nous d'avoir toutes ces infos en
attendant je vous invite à aller
consulter ma playlist pour connaître
tous les smartphones qui le sont par
contre déjà sortis et bien évidemment
rester connecté parce qu'on a toujours
parlé beaucoup plus de smartphones et
puis de plein d'autres produits ici il
ya tellement de produits
vous allez voir va y avoir des tests
plein show d'ici quelques jours voilà
d'ici là soyez sages passer de bonnes
fêtes
on est sur la fin d'année je vous
embrasse et à bientôt ciao
m